you're trapped in a house alone the
doors won't open the windows won't break
during the day nothing much happens but
at night well let's just say you're not
alone anymore
[Music]
hello Internet
welcome to film theory bringing the
spooky to you way before Halloween comes
around still it'd be three tailors
though I mean there are jack-o'-lanterns
and scarecrows on display at my local
grocery store right now come on people
let's summer have it's time today though
in that spirit of horror we're covering
what I consider to be a modern era Blair
Witch Project a homegrown YouTube horror
story that's put me more on edge than
anything I've seen in theaters for the
past few years there's a certain comfort
you have in structures you know if a
movie is rated pg-13 or R you know the
level of scare that they're gonna be
able to reach within that movie and
there's a level of comfort there you
know something has to be commercially
marketable to make it into a theater and
whether you realize it or not that gives
you a certain level of safety stories
and movies have three acts after all and
whether the resolution of that movie is
good or bad it's still a movie it's
still going to have to resolve horror
stories that exist online though don't
work that way it's the sort of horror
that you can't find anywhere else it's
raw it's unpolished it's unpredictable
it rips away all of those safety nets
that we hold dear and as a result it's
able to deliver experiences that truly
chill you to the core which is why today
we're talking about hi I'm Mary Mary
Channel I've had my eye on for a while
and one that after I covered local 58 a
lot of you requested me talk about fair
warning this is not one to watch a night
[ __ ] in headphones honestly because the
sound design is literally the most
unsettling part of it partly because of
the creep factor but mostly because
audio normalization is
not a tool Mary's toolset now for the
majority of you who've never heard of
this channel let me give you a little
bit of background hi I'm Mary Mary was
created in 2016 with a video simply
titled hello where were introduced to
marry a girl who awakens in a house with
no memory of how she got there what she
can tell us is that she's in what she
thinks is her parents house or at least
a copy of it and she's unable to leave
the doors are locked the windows won't
break she has a camera and access to the
Internet but otherwise she's completely
alone even on the Internet even when she
has access to Twitter which let's be
honest I know this is supposed to be a
horror series and all but Twitter
without people screaming at you doesn't
sound like a nightmare sounds more like
a dream come true during the day nothing
much happens but at night well maybe
Mary isn't as alone as she thinks she is
the first video ends abruptly as we
catch a glimpse of a shadowy woman
wearing a black veil over the next few
uploads were introduced to the scariest
4 housemates you could ever want four
distinct entities each acting in their
own unique way each stalking and
attacking her as she tries to survive
inside the house for the majority of the
series she spends her time in that home
learning the rules of this new reality
that she suddenly found herself in
eventually however she stumbles into a
new location somewhere outside a place
she calls the garden a place where she's
finally able to catch a break from all
the monsters that exist inside her house
a place where she's joined by a version
of herself dressed all in white
but even that soon reveals itself to be
a trap as she frequents the garden to
escape from her home more and more even
the garden begins to change into
something much more sinister and that's
not all Mary Mary is a story that spills
out of its videos and over into her blog
and Twitter account with each outlet
providing different pieces to the puzzle
of what's really going on in Mary Mary's
world vague additional details from the
tweets unreleased thoughts and images in
her blog secret messages hidden in that
web site source code in the source code
people mary mary isn't just a horror
story about one young woman's torture my
friends it is a complete Arg experience
just waiting for us to decipher so
what's the theory today oh we're just
trying to figure out
what's really going on if the premise
didn't already tip you off that there
might be something deeper at play here
the sudden appearance of a mirror
version of yourself in a Garden of Eden
while you're fighting literal demons
back in your whorehouse seems like this
story might be pretty darn symbolic so
that my friends is our goal today expose
the evils haunting Mary Mary
and in the process answer the cries for
help she's been leaving across her blog
and Twitter and before we begin I know I
already made a warning earlier about the
series but it does bear one final
warning here as we get started this
series is a really dark it gets intense
it deals with some very real very heavy
subjects and it does so in a way that
feels very personal so what I would say
is watch it for the entertainment watch
it for the scares take it in small doses
but if any of the imagery or topics that
it addresses starts to affect you in any
way we've included phone lines from
around the world who are there and
available for calls and help down in the
description below
again the fact that I'm saying that sort
of disclaimer on a series that was
created by a young woman here on YouTube
and not any of the other wacky stuff
that we've ever covered on this channel
should really tell you a lot about how
effective hi I'm Mary Mary really is at
delivering a hard-hitting narrative
so with those disclaimers out of the way
let's begin the easiest place to start
our analysis and the thing that starts
toppling some of the other dominoes in
this puzzle is with the character Beauty
one of the monsters that stalks Mary
around the house appearing only when
Mary looks at a mirror wearing a tight
black or purple dress and sporting a
flawless mask it's not too hard to
identify Beauty as the embodiment of
Mary's physical insecurities beauty
constantly mocks Mary and laughs at her
imperfections this character represents
Mary being haunted by the fears that she
has over her own self-image the fact
that she won't be able to live up to the
societal pressures of what she should
look and behave like pressures from
social media mainstream media even her
peers according to the Millennial cohort
study a study that looks into financial
well-being parenting education and
health and children almost 40% of girls
who spend more than five hours a day on
social media shows signs of depression
and of those with depression they're
two-and-a-half times more likely than
boys to be dissatisfied
with their appearance that is the
essence of beauty so if one of the
monsters that are haunting Mary is an
expression of her own personal fears and
insecurities in this case her
self-loathing it stands to reason that
the others must be as well right well
it's a theory that certainly seems to
hold true for our second monster the
veiled lady the first one that were
introduced to during those final moments
in Episode one found in videos hello
worse discovery do not touch hide and
seek check in rain gone in last eight
months when we first meet the veiled
lady she's just a creepy thing that we
see at the end of a video however as
this series continues on and as more and
more of the monsters show up in her
house the more aggressive the veiled
lady becomes not only does she appear
more frequently than all the other
entities and appear to be a ringleader
of sorts she's also the only one who's
able to directly speak with Mary in the
video titled hide and seek we get an
interesting interaction where the veiled
lady asks Mary to participate in the
game of questions and answers when Mary
asks the veiled lady what she wants we
get ourselves a pretty straightforward
answer
that answer fairly well spells it out
the veiled lady is symbolic of
depression and it's that depression
that's acting as the root cause of
everything else that's happening inside
the house
the reason the veiled lady appears the
most frequently of all the monsters the
reason she gets stronger as more of
those monsters appear is because they
all feed in to her they all feed in to
depression take beauty for instance
those insecurities of not being good
enough of not meeting society's
pressures for physical appearance those
all feed back into the depression that
Mary is feeling making it grow deeper
making it grow stronger the same will
hold true of all the other monsters that
we're about to discuss later in the game
of questions and answers Mary asks a
different question who are you
and the veiled lady responds
this is quite a literal answer Mary does
indeed know the names of all the issues
that she's dealing with things like
depression self-doubt anxiety
self-loathing and if that doesn't drive
our theory home when Mary asks yet
another question the veiled lady
responds with Oh Mary you already know
after all you made us given us pretty
solid evidence that these monsters are
indeed all products that exist inside
Mary's own mind so that's two of the
four monsters in the house and quite
honestly they're the two most obvious
the others are a bit more speculative
but I think I've got a good handle on
him we'll call the third one the shadow
because it's a human silhouette found in
the episodes goodnight sleepwalker and
rain the shadow is most notably seen
approaching Mary in situations where she
feels safe we see it looming over her
while she's on the Internet we see it
crawling over the foot of the bed as
she's sleeping other than that it
doesn't really do all that much outside
of being creepy there is however another
notable trait that it seems to carry
with it whatever it's round we tend to
see phrases flash on-screen I feel
nothing is one of the most obvious we
can find this statement along with other
related sentiments on Mary's Twitter
saying things like I hate looking at it
what does it even do it just follows me
around and when I look at it I feel all
terrible in fact that theme of looking
at the shadow and feeling bad seems to
be the primary things that she's trying
to communicate to us about this entity
in another tweet about the shadow quote
I don't like looking at it staring
directly makes me feel bad this in my
mind seems to point to the shadow being
representative of regret regret is one
of those things that lingers that
follows you around and that you can
largely ignore but once you start
thinking about it once you start looking
at it you start to feel really bad about
yourself and the decisions that you've
made in the past it makes you feel like
a terrible person it's slow it's
creeping and regret never truly goes
away exactly the things that mary says
about the shadow on twitter quote it's
watching me why doesn't it move
quickly it's like it wants me to feel
like this it's looking at me right now
at least I think it is I'm gonna go into
another room and close the door
it will probably open it regret looms
over you
it follows behind you it's like a shadow
in sleepwalker we see the phrase I
messed up over and over and over and
over again on the wall as it creeps up
behind her and not seconds later it's on
the couch uncomfortably close the messed
up tells us exactly what we need to know
here Mary made a bad decision and the
shadow is the entity that reminds her of
that which is why the next phrase that
we see in the briefest of flashes is I
get what I deserve
she made a mistake and now she feels
like the shadow is her punishment the
thing that she rightfully earned because
of that mistake
based on the intimacy of the shadow the
fact that it's able to get so close to
her the fact that it's largely
associated with the bed and sleeping I'd
say this is a series of regrets born out
of getting intimate too early in a
relationship or getting pressured to do
things that she wasn't quite ready for
which would not only prompt the regret
that she's experiencing but also that
empty nothingness that she feels
whenever she's reminded of that moment
by the shadow what should have felt
special is now cold hollow empty she
feels nothing which leaves us with one
final entity in the house the darkness
found in the episodes darkness moves do
not touch and the last eight months the
darkness isn't so much a humanoid figure
like the others but rather a spidery
essence that branches and creeps around
on Mary's Twitter she plays a game with
her future self called guess which
entity based on the ways to deal with it
and while she has a solid solution for
three of those entities the darkness is
the one that confuses her the most let's
look at those tweets and play along
shall we don't hang out near mirrors
obviously referring to beauty move
around every once in a while don't
settle in one place and especially don't
fall asleep the reference to sleep here
seems to indicate to us that this is the
shadow run very very fast and also hide
but you can't hide for long because
she's smart enough to find you so you
have to do it all night well since Mary
specifically refers to this one as a she
we have a very obvious connection to
beauty in the other tweet this is
definitely referring to the veiled lady
but the
get to tweet number four and we have
ourselves one last remaining contestant
in this little game show the darkness
still not sure about this one try your
best to ignore it and stay far away from
it in the video do not touch
she actually catches the darkness but
instead of being in her poem when she
turns her hand around it's stuck on her
palm with the words I'm a monster
appearing on screen immediately after at
this point we suddenly enter a frantic
montage of scenes where were shown all
the other entities in the house in rapid
succession something of note here is
that boundaries suddenly seem to be gone
Beauty is no longer trapped inside
mirrors and is able to remove her mask
revealing the ugliness underneath the
shadow has suddenly grown taller the
veiled lady looks way more enraged and
aggressive than normal since all of this
craziness happens right after the
darkness absorbs itself into Mary I'm
inclined to think that this one
represents anxiety and do not touch Mary
chases after the darkness it's actually
one of the few times in the entire
series that she tries to face her demons
head-on but when she finally gets a
handle on it what does she get in return
basically a panic attack she's
overwhelmed by all the entities
attacking her all at once to a degree
that the series has yet to see and the
behavior of anxiety matches the actions
of the darkness anxiety can creep and
slowly devour you or it can just jump
out and attack you all at once
unprompted it entangles you it ensnares
you it amplifies all your existing
problems to a new extreme an anxiety has
no face it has no name or identity
instead it's the collection of all your
other problems balled up and tangled
into one all of this matches how the
darkness behaves when it sunscreen and
hi I'm Mary Mary when it absorbs itself
into Mary suddenly all her existing
problems get amplified and attack all at
once the darkness may not seem like a
lot but it's literally inescapable able
to strike anywhere at any moment so
those are our four monsters but the
house Mary's trapped in representing her
mind a house that is plagued by demons
of depression anxiety regret and
self-loathing but our story isn't done
there's a fifth and final monster we've
yet to cover one that doesn't roam the
house one that lurks outside one that
may just be the most
sinister and dangerous evil of them all
but more on that in an upcoming episode
if you guys really like this one maybe I
can squeeze it in for next week let me
know down in the comments if you like
this one and if you want me to continue
analyzing the series if you do make sure
you hit the subscribe button you see on
screen right now but in the meantime
while you wait for that video to get
released check out the box to the left
where I cover local 58 an equally creepy
scary story right here on YouTube an
undiscovered gem go and check that one
out just make sure that you stay safe oh
yeah and remember that it's all just a
theory of film